tu vas faire le train tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention à la fermeture automatique des
pommes attention au départ
[Musique]
bienvenue à la gare de Paris
Montparnasse
tous les trains sont supprimés ce soir
pour que de retard et de grève
indéterminé
c'est extraordinaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens détourner
[Musique]
les un très grand appétit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à celui-là
[Applaudissements]
merci les chats
[Musique]
merci à plus tard Hafida
Turner il y a tout donné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous
merci alors
merci
à plus tard
[Applaudissements]
bravo vous avez été exceptionnel
venez nous rejoindre pour la fin de
l'émission parce que il faut que je vous
parle à tous les deux j'ai un truc à
vous dire
bonjour à toute l'équipe de Paris
Montparnasse ouais les agents d'escal la
sûreté ferroviaire il recrute la sûreté
ferroviaire
à Paris de partout
et dédicace à balance TGV à Émilie aussi
à Anthony Chambéry l'officier de
Grenoble à tout le monde merci à tous
d'être là et surtout merci à tous les
clients d'être là les pompiers aussi
merci les pompiers non par là on vous
adore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci bonne soirée à tous
tu veux le refaire un peu
tu veux pas faire le dernier coupé le
dernier couplet quand même avec Dylan
mais Dylan fait des annonces un peu de
la SNCF le coup
c'est parti
je vais regarder sur le portable
[Musique]